une autre inquiétude l approche de la
légalisation de la marijuana
les médecins du québec s'inquiètent des
effets de la légalisation du cannabis
dans les mois qui ont précédé la
légalisation du cannabis aux pays de
nombreux experts se sont dits inquiets
on craignait en prendre qu'un plus grand
nombre de jeunes consomment des jeunes
plus vulnérables aux conséquences
néfastes de marijuana
on constate que finalement un peu comme
le bogue de l'an 2000 la menace qu'on
percevait ne se manifeste pas si la
catastrophe annoncée n'a pas eu lieu
c'est entre autres parce que la santé
publique a mis l'accent sur la
prévention
on pensait qu'une approche prudente
serait probablement mieux indiqué qu'une
approche de prohibition
les plus récentes données de statistique
canada démontrent que le nombre de
canadiens âgés de 15 ans et plus qui
consomment du cannabis est resté stable
malgré la légalisation
il semble pas y avoir plus de
consommation et on a des données très
très partiel ce qui regarde par exemple
gestion des services hospitaliers et les
quelques informations que j'ai moins un
medic pas vraiment lieu de s'alarmer au
project tumulus où on sensibilise les
jeunes aux dangers de la dépendance
on note même quelques différences
positives
une différence internet questionnement
oui et différence en termes de avoir
fait tomber des tabous d'addiction oui
les tabous ou semble être tombé entre
autres chez les parents les parents qui
nous appellent c'est effectivement ça on
se pose la question de comment on peut
l'aborder avec notre enfant de questions
poser de questions ne t'avise qu'est-ce
qu'on ne tarissent pas les consommateurs
qui fréquentent la société québécoise du
cannabis se sont aussi plus en sécurité
et on peut vraiment avoir la certitude
qu on sait qu est-ce qu on semble le
sentiment de sécurité aussi l'option 6
comprend au cours des prochaines
semaines
les produits comestibles à base de
cannabis arriveront sur les tablettes
cette étape suscite de nouvelles
inquiétudes on craint que ces types de
produits deviennent pour les jeunes en
particulier
mode de consommation cool québec a déjà
annoncé que la vente de chocolats de
friandises et de confiseries à base de
cannabis sera interdite sur son
territoire une bonne chose pour la santé
publique qui encore une fois prendre la
prudence et la prévention
et si catherine gauthier radio canada
montréal